بعد عشره وزواج دام لسنوات طلقها والسبب
اكتسابها بعض الكيلوات الزائده فما القصه
[موسيقى]
عرفتي جوزك ازاي عن طريق الشغل كنا شغالين
سوا قعدتوا مخطوبين قد ايه سنه
طيب في فتره الخطوبه هل كان كثير
التعليقات على اللبس والشكل والكلام ده
ولا يعني اتغير لا خالص ولكن في اي كومنت
مثلا على لبسي ولا على شكلي بالعكس يمكن
كان بيقعد يقول لي مثلا بحب شكلك وانت
مليانه وقلبوظه
وكده
[موسيقى]
وبعدين ايه اللي حصل ما فيش بعد كده انا
قعدت سنه متجوزه
واول ما جبت لوجي وزني زاد يعني مثلا زاد
مثلا 10 كيلو 15 كيلو بعد الولاده على طول
فهو اداني فرصه ان انا لازم اخس وكده
دايني شكلي ما كانش عاجبه بقى في التخن
قوي قال لي انت قدامك مثلا شهرين لو ما
خسيتيش فيهم فمش هنكمل مع بعض عملت ساعتها
بلون اللي هو بالون المعده ده ونزلت فيها
عشرين كيلو ورجعت بعد ما شلتها على طول
بعد ست شهور زدت العشرين كيلو 40 طب ما
يعني احنا كلنا كل الستات بتكسب كيلوات
ووزن بعد ما تخلف يعني دي طبيعه جسم اي ست
في الدنيا لا خالص هو بدا باي يعلق لي على
اي حاجه انت وزنك زاد انت مش بتعملي الشقه
انت مش زي الستات مش بتنزلي مش بتروحي ومش
بتيجي عايزه
عايزه شكلك يتغير انا بتكسف همشي معاكي مش
بحب شكلك كده
بس هو كان رفيع زياده عن اللازم فكان
بيطلع وقالوا عليا بقى
رغم ان انا وانا مليانه كان شكلي احسن من
كده كمان بكتير يعني بيتهيالي كان شكلي
قلبوظه كده وحلوه يعني
[موسيقى]
بصي في الاول انا كنت بس مستغربه زي ما
الناس اللي حواليا كلهم كانوا مستغربين
ازاي انت تعترض عليها ان هي مثلا زادت
شويه اذا كان اهله اهلي كانوا حاسين ان في
حاجه تاني كبيره هو مش قادر يقولها
بس قعدوا يحاولوا معه كتير ان هو يقر مثلا
ويقول دي عملت كذا او في مشكله كبيره ما
كناش بنلاقي مشكله فده اللي كان مخليني ان
انا مستغربه
بس شويه كده وخلاص يعني موضوع انتهى عشتي
حياتك ازاي بعد الفتره الصعبه دي ولا اي
حاجه كنت باكل وعايشه حياتي عادي ولا
اهتميت بالعكس يعني الاول لو كنت بفكر ان
انا اعمل عمليه بقى واخص الكلام ده بعديها
ما بقاش عندي خالص انا حابه نفسي كده انت
ست قويه وواثقه في نفسها وهي دي احلى حاجه
فيك
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات